what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I am lucky enough to get to
talk to the team behind the Persian
version congratulations your movie is
just electric I love The Vibes and I
love the depth and I have a whole lot of
questions about like the tone and style
of your movie that we're gonna get into
but congratulations thank you so much
all right Miriam you have to do this
okay I have a feeling you've been asked
this a million times thus far but I know
the Persian version our audience does
not just yet so can you give a brief
synopsis if you're moving uh the Persian
version is about
um a daughter who comes home to her
family in New Jersey after her her
father is having a heart transplant so
while everyone is in the hospital she's
staying home to take care of her
grandmother and she uncovers a family
secret and she's always had problems
with her relation with her mother and in
understanding what the secret is she
retraces her relationship with her
mother through several decades and
realizes she's not as different from her
mother than she thought Chapel done you
had practice didn't you
can you tell us a little bit about
pinpointing the right I guess the right
I hate boxing things into a single genre
because that is not what this movie is
so maybe the right assortment of genres
to be able to tell this story because it
really is a beautiful and very effective
balance of comedy and drama in
particular here I really definitely want
to make a dramedy I want to make it a
great immigrant story I grew up watching
films like The Godfather or namesake
um or Wedding Banquet or My Big Fat
Greek Wedding and I I wanted to do
something that was reflective of my
family of my culture and that means both
laughing crying all of the machinations
of big families I grew up with seven
brothers in one bathroom it's not
autobiographical in the movie it's it's
eight brothers in my real life it's
seven so it's totally fiction
um but yeah I wanted to have something
that could reflect my experience my
experience of being part of two cultures
I grew up between I was born in New York
but I like to smuggle tapes into Iran I
used to go to Iran a lot and I was a
Smuggler of music into Iran Michael
Jackson Prince Cindy Lauper because back
then after the revolution western music
became forbidden and my cousins were
dying for music so I used to stick it in
my underwear and just bring it across
the border and I would emerge and the
dancing would begin and in America we
grew up struggling economically but our
communities always got together the
Persian community and we would listen to
Persian Pop music so music pop music in
particular of the both countries are
very important and then the film ends
with a Persian version of The Girls Just
Want to Have Fun sung by new shinur and
composed by rostam Batman she's our
composer from Vampire Weekend who's also
Iranian American and queer so it was the
east meets west as a way to end the
movie on my favorite song growing up I
really Girls Just Want to Have Fun you
know I couldn't imagine a better way to
end this movie for the two of you and
now I'm curious when you book these
roles what would you say is the biggest
difference between how you pictured your
character day one and then who they
turned out to be as you got to explore
them or while you were making the movie
and working with this Ensemble yeah I
feel like finding the empathy with this
character was in an incredible journey
um she's been through so much and she
always felt like you know she didn't
have a place of belonging in either
countries she always loved both
countries but she didn't feel like she
belonged to neither one she didn't feel
accepted with her mother she felt like
you know she wasn't
able to be who she was and be loved by
her mother that's what she thought and
so I think you know being able to do
this with nusha
um
it was an incredible experience just
like finding her and realizing it's okay
to be tough and the reason she's tough
is because she's trying to understand
why she feels like an outsider in her
own family there's eight boys and she's
the only girl so it's hard for her to
open up so that was something that I
learned on the journey because coming in
I read it and I saw so many layers to
Miriam and then you know talking to her
and trying to understand her and how you
know she was I've got on the phone with
her multiple times and anytime she would
tell me a story I'd jot little things
down because I wanted to just do her
justice and honor her story the way that
she wanted it done so are you sure you
did that I think I did yeah I hope I did
it but yeah I don't mean to cut you off
Noosa but just to follow up on that what
is what's like a seemingly silly detail
that you wrote down that wound up being
important to to think about to to make
your version of Miriam feel whole in
this movie yeah definitely that it was
okay to be
tougher like her relationship with
um Tom's character who plays Hedwig
um
she didn't want this it wasn't planned
so I think it was really important in
the beginning she was telling me you
know it's it happened on accident she
had just gotten out of a relationship
she went to this party she wore this
incredible birkatini Halloween costume
which was phenomenal and you know she
went she you know what happens when that
happens exactly something happens and it
changed her life forever and careful
what you wear to Halloween parties it
could change her life yeah
but it's that strong independent woman
who doesn't want someone to control her
she wanted to be able to do this her way
she was going to have a you know she
that's why her and her first
relationship didn't work out because she
didn't want to have to give up her life
and her opportunities and she wanted to
you know live her dreams and so it's
similar to what the mother wants exactly
able to do so I think it's also about
women being told they can't do something
and they find a way to be authentic to
themselves I think you know
my mother's cornish's character is told
that she can't finish school she has to
get married and she in fact that's what
happens but later on she finds a way to
not only finish school but become Ultra
successful and at every turn they're
paralleling each other's stories they
just don't realize it Society has told
both of them they can't be who they want
to be and they find a way but in the
process they've kind of alienated each
other so it's about finding that
connection through storytelling and
through narrative and I think you did
initiatives she plays so many ages in
the films very impressive I mean I guess
I guess I have to go back to that
beginning question especially because
you're playing so many ages what what is
the biggest difference between day one
your vision of that character and who
she turned out to be as you explored all
those phases of her life you know um
this character I mean there's so many
complexities and layers to her and I
think for me really studying that and
the psychology of what she actually went
through the traumas and almost when she
moved here some sort of you know like
just disassociating for what she went
through wanting to start new and and
she's so driven and she's driven by this
uh Inner Strength that she you know
pushed her to rise from being a
housewife to a business uh Mogul but
um for me it was just finding all the
nuances in the layers of her character
why she does what she does
um why is her relationship with her
daughter so complicated and I I
discovered a lot and I had the pleasure
of speaking to her mother and asking
certain questions which you know I
didn't I was like what can I ask what
can I not uh she might not tell you the
truth but but just being so inspired by
her and
I I it was
I think I just got to know her more and
also my own mother because
um the sacrifices that she made and uh
like you said something earlier about I
don't know like we kind of always grow
up thinking our mother is just mother we
don't think that they have a past and
all these secrets and traumas and things
and I you know at maybe at 25 or
something got to know my mother on a
different layer and all the things that
she went through that I didn't know so
there's a lot of similarities and
stories that were ran uh parallel
um and it was it was yeah it was a great
experience I think writing it it's like
to
put aside like that this title of mother
or father and think of your parents as
13 and 14 and teenagers it was
eye-opening and humbling and I had to
really dig deep enough and push myself
to think of things from her point of
view and that was
really changed my relationship to myself
to my own daughter to my mother I
realized also when I became a parent men
were just faking it we have no idea what
we're doing but here's this little kid
thinks I'm like you know you know I know
what I'm doing but and that really was
also eye-opening to me you know we
struggled so much we think that we're
born being mothers you know we're born
with the instincts we know exactly what
to do it's you know that's what Society
has told us but it's not true it's you
become a mother through the process of
having to make the right decisions and
sometimes you don't always make the
right decisions and I think it's about
forgiving each other and you know
finding a way that we're just we're
these are two women that have to
understand each other as women not only
as mother and daughter speaking of that
exploring that in a movie probably
requires the ultimate scene partner and
I always love talking about the value of
a good scene partner so for each of you
can you tell me something about the
other that you appreciated and maybe
helped you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without them
the amount of empathy and just
when I wasn't even my coverage I was
crying during some of her take she's so
open and honest and wears her heart on
her sleeve and taught me so much this
was my first film so I went in nervous
and she was just a Guiding Light her and
Miriam I just
she's an everybody to be honest there's
every single person in this cast put so
much into their characters there wasn't
one person who didn't respect someone's
process or give them and there were so
many first-timers you know the young
version of of my mother is played by a
14 year old from Iran she's incredible
incredible high school student never
acted she has a four-page monologue in
one shot and you know young young Layla
obviously he's just eight years old and
I think there and then we have new shows
like a trained actor who's been in many
things and it was a nice mix of people's
experience but I think it was you guys
all connected really well and I think we
also spent a lot of time in rehearsal it
was very important to me not just
casting great actors but cast people who
would put their ego aside and become
part of a family a rehearsal process
although we didn't have much of it every
day we had off we rehearsed and we
changed dialogue and we made it more fun
and more funny and more real and that's
that was so important to me and I think
through the process everyone got to
connect with each other absolutely yeah
I wish I have how about something for
you that Layla helped uh bring out of
your own character
um I remember thinking this and I in the
beginning we didn't bond as much because
we weren't she was we're in different
scenes until the end but I remember
thinking is this really her first film
because you're such a pro I mean that
I've told you there was one night in New
York and I was drinking and I was like
listen I need to tell you something
you're a star you want the it Factor
you're amazing
um and I generally meant that um and
same with her just having these very
complicated scenes emotional scenes
um looking at her and just seeing the
genuineness I suppose and
um just really she allowed me to feel
and go there to those places easily um
and of course with the direction of
Mariam and and the notes that she would
give it was it was it was
it was it was really and I agree with
you it's really important who you work
with and um to continue what Magnum was
saying this whole cast like we all knew
that we had something special and we
were there's no egos we were just on the
same page we knew this was a special
story and it hasn't been done before
that hasn't been an iranian-american you
know immigration story with this sort of
like you just it just like I was saying
before I painted a really Fuller picture
of who we are as Iranians and we don't
really have that we haven't had that and
also the dynamic it's like their Dynamic
they're sparring amidst a huge family of
men and it's all the men also navigating
their thorny relationships and how the
brothers react and that's also an
important place the setting and the and
the tapestry of where they're having
their scenes and all the men in the
background is so important to feel like
they're trying to it's a chess game and
everyone you know I think the the scene
the dinners you know the lunch scene is
so important because you see all the
other characters who have small rules
but they really are setting the backdrop
for their relationships so you you have
a sense of this family I was really
impressed by how memorable the
supporting Ensemble is because you have
a really large group of people and I
feel like someone could get lost in the
mix but like I knew every single brother
was so distinct right
it's screen presence too and it's it's
believability not just in terms of the
events of their lives that we're
experiencing right now while watching
the movie but feeling the history that's
influencing it too and it's very
effective they're going to make me uh
leave you guys soon but I wanted to ask
about one specific technique you use
because I think it's one of the most
difficult things to do and make work in
a film breaking the fourth wall having
gone through this experience and anyone
can chime in on this what would you say
is maybe like a do an adult when you
incorporate that kind of Storytelling in
a script wow it is very challenging like
technically and also to make it not
because it can be a distancing technique
right because you're talking to the
audience and it but here I wanted it to
be the opposite I wanted it to be the
character confiding in the audience and
the character demanding their own voice
I always knew that it would be three
stories from three women
I think what brought it is that in
Layla's versions that that technique is
typically used in a comedic way
and I think in the in the later versions
it's more to reveal the character's true
deep desires
um I think we use it a little bit
differently I think it's a very tricky
technique
um I was terrified I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna lie
um but I felt it it was what was needed
for the story it wasn't just a cool
technique that when Layla stops time in
our film she sets the language that
women or this character has the power to
stop time and that that baton is passed
through the generations in different
ways because Layla is not only the
filmmaker and the Storyteller but guess
what every generation is a Storyteller
when they come to a new country and they
demand that they stop time and so that
was I knew that there had to be the
technique visually for us to connect the
storytelling Generations in some way
very very well done in that respect and
many and also just say first film is
just like wild to me you you approach
the role and things like that with such
Authority and I can only speak from my
limited perspective I don't know how you
felt doing all that but it makes all of
that radiate off screen and undeniable
screen presence I'm sure I'm going to
talk to you again in the future same
with you and you as well huge
congratulations on the Persian version
thank you so much thanks for having us
everybody out there keep an eye out for
the Persian version and for more
interviews right here from sundance2023
very soon